[Music]
you may think that having a stroke is
unlikely but stroke is the leading cause
of disability in American adults this
doesn't mean that damaged caused by
stroke is unpreventable the soon of a
stroke victim receives treatment the
lower their risk of lifelong disability
or death because of this it's important
to be able to recognize the signs of a
stroke so that you can come to the aid
of yourself or others should a stroke
occur a stroke happens when blood flow
is unable to reach an area of the brain
like the rest of the body brain cells
depend on oxygen which is supplied by
the blood stream without it brain cells
begin to die and the functions
associated with them such as sensation
muscle control and memory are lost in
the event of a stroke it's important to
recognize the signs fast face have the
person's smile does one side of their
face droop downwards
arms have the person raise their arms
does one arm sag down speech is the
person's speech slurred or unusual in
some other way
time in the event of any of these signs
call 911 assistance stroke can occur in
anybody at any time but equipped with
the proper knowledge you can be a
lifesaver
you
[Music]